[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing voldemort bellatrix unusual
family dynamics and their daughter
that's right you heard me their daughter
for those unaware in the cursed child
which was written for a post harry
potter world it's revealed that at one
point in time bellatrix and voldemort
conceived a child of their own delfini
what's interesting about this however is
that this would have actually happened
during the original harry potter story
before bellatrix suffers her fate at the
hands of molly weasley's spell in
today's video i want to break all of
this down explaining how it happened why
it happened and when it happened so sit
back relax and enjoy
now before we get started i know the
cursed child isn't popular it's marketed
as the eighth story a continuation
following the children of the characters
that we grew up with the events of the
cursed child occurred 19 years after the
events of the deathly hallows and
followed harry potter who was now head
of the department of magical law
enforcement the ministry of magic and
his younger son albus potter who's just
about to embark on his own journey at
hogwarts
but rather than being made into a film
adaptation the cursed child was made
into a two-part play rather than a
feature film the play primarily comes
under scrutiny from harry potter fans
because of its apparent disregard for
the traditional harry potter canon
though rolling has affirmed that the
play should be accepted as part of the
canon most fans aren't having any of
this this is for a couple of reasons
first of all the storyline truly upsets
our perceptions of the traditional harry
potter universe the notion that
voldemort could have a child when he was
born entirely devoid of certain emotions
is just one example of something that
the cursed child did that didn't sit
well with fans the next big issue for
most fans is that rowling didn't write
the play all on her own
because other people had influence on
how the play and story would turn out it
seems to be the general consensus among
fans that it can't truly be canon on the
front cover it very clearly reads based
on an original new story by jk rowling
john tiffany and jack thorne but just
for a moment let's entertain the version
of canon introduced by the cursed child
and the absurd notion that voldemort
devoid of emotion and social graces
could possibly conceive a child with his
right hand woman and resident wizarding
world lunatic bellatrix lestrange the
conception of delfini voldemort and
bellatrix's daughter occurred sometime
in the mid to late 1990s in secret at
the malfoy manor this of course meant
that her birth coincided with the events
of the original books we just never had
any indication of it furthermore delfini
who also goes by delphi and the cursed
child became the only known living heir
of salazar sutherin after voldemort died
in the battle of hogwarts in 1998. her
birth was kept a secret by her parents
because they feared that their infamous
reputations would place her in danger
especially in the event of their deaths
it is unknown what her relationship was
like with her parents or how they felt
about her as they both died while she
was still a baby
but she still went on to inherit many
traits from both of them as she grew
older she became increasingly cruel
sadistic violent ruthless obsessive
manipulative cunning charismatic and
intelligent the list goes on her
calculated determined and most of all
ruthless nature meant that she would
eventually go on to commit murder
murdering craig boca jr a fellow student
at hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry this act swiftly landed her in
azkaban prison and it proved that she
really did take after her mother and
father she was also fierce tempered and
would easily lose control if things went
awry another trait she inherited from
her mother and father we'll go back to
delphi's story later but first i want to
look at the impetus for why bellatrix
and voldemort would have even wanted a
child let alone how let's break down
their motivations bellatrix lestrange
was one of the most feared witches in
the wizarding world her fear-inspiring
name and bloodthirsty reputation were
well deserved and she was known to have
murdered and tortured many many witches
and wizards but that impressive resume
aside belichick's estranged was first
and foremost lord voldemort's most loyal
follower one that would serve him
unquestionably so if voldemort wanted a
child with bellatrix i'm sure that she
would have been more than willing to
oblige he was her master and i think
that conceiving a child with him would
have been an honor for her whether she
actually wanted one or not voldemort on
the other hand is a bit more complicated
voldemort is perhaps the most feared
dark wizard of all time feared so much
that most of the wizarding world was
afraid to even utter his name voldemort
achieved power that others could only
dream of he was an intelligent cunning
and manipulative man that amassed a
legion of followers at the height of his
power despite appearing to care for his
followers this wasn't the case as
voldemort truly did not care for anyone
he had no understanding of empathy
whatsoever and simply used those around
him to more quickly achieve his goal of
power
part of the reason for voldemort's
incapability of feeling things like love
was because of the way that he himself
was conceived you see voldemort's mother
murapi used a love potion on his father
tom riddle senior effectively forcing
him into a relationship with her because
of this voldemort was cursed with an
existence in which he would never be
able to feel love himself
some people have looked at the birth of
delfini as proof of voldemort's ability
to feel love but i think they're really
wrong on that i don't think voldemort
cared for bellatrix or even loved her he
simply saw childbirth through more of a
utilitarian lens voldemort was arrogant
and probably felt that he could live
forever but it doesn't hurt to have a
backup plan a way to continue the
lineage of salazar slytherin in the
event of his demise and what better way
to ensure an heir to the throne of
slytherin than by procreating with his
powerful right-hand woman so that's my
theory for why voldemort simply wanted
to continue his bloodline and though
childbirth and raising a child didn't
interest him at all the thought of his
powerful lineage ending would have been
a perishing one for the dark lord this
is where it gets a bit scandalous though
as bellatrix lestrange was not a free
agent delfini's mother was a married
woman and not voldemort that's right
bellatrix lestrange was born bellatrix
black and was married into the lestrange
family when she wed rodolfos lestrange a
fellow death eater and servant of
voldemort so was rodolfos aware of all
of this i think he was but i don't think
that he had any objection to it because
the very nature of bellatrix and
rodolfos's relationship was almost
political they were both pure bloods
that came from supremacist families and
for mainly this reason got together
bellatrix's attention being drawn to
voldemort only meant that rodolfos would
be able to go about his business without
further distractions or responsibilities
in fact bellatrix being chosen to
produce offspring with the dark lord
himself was probably a source of pride
for him he was first and foremost a
follower of lord voldemort and a husband
to bellatrix second
after the battle of hogwarts both
voldemort and bellatrix were dead but
rodolfo survived and was subsequently
sent to azgaban interestingly enough it
was actually rodolfos delphini's
stepfather that ended up informing her
of her heritage as there was no one else
around to do it that brings us to how
well i'm sure you all know the tale of
the birds and the bees and that's
probably how it happened assuming all
parties were on board there are even
some passages from the book which could
allude to this night of passion the
first relates to voldemort maniacal
laughter was ringing in his ears
voldemort was happier than he had been
in a very long time jubilant ecstatic
triumphant a wonderful wonderful thing
had happened and the second relates to
bellatrix
my lord my lord it was bellatrix's voice
and she spoke as if to a lover
anyway that's it for this video what do
you guys think of my thoughts regarding
the birth of delfini comment down below
until next time remember it is our
choices that show what we truly are far
more than our abilities
you